AND A WINE CORK IS HER BARSTOOL.
THIS WEEKEND, THE 40TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE GREATEST
SPORTS UPSET EVER WHEN THE U.S.
OLYMPIC TEAM BEAT THE RUSSIANS
IN HOCKEY.
UP TO THAT END, THE RED ARMY
TEAM HAD ONE MAKE A PREVIOUS
FOUR GOLD MEDALS DATING BACK TO
1960.
THE LAST TIME A U.S. TEAM WOULD
BUY GOLD.
AS A KID YOU CAN REMEMBER
SITTING IN FRONT OF A TV
TRANSFIXED, WITNESSING HISTORY,
AND MY COMPLETE HAPPY BUT YOU
HAVE TO WONDER WHERE
BERNIE SANDERS WAS BACK THEN AND
WHO HE WAS ROOTING FOR.
HERE’S BERNIE FROM THE 80s.
>> IT’S FUNNY.
SOMETIMES TALK ABOUT HOW BAD A
COUNTRY IS, PEOPLE ARE LINING UP
FOR FOOD.
IN OTHER COUNTRIES, PEOPLE DON’T
LINE UP FOR FOOD FOR THE RICH
GET THE FOOD AND THE POOR STARVE
TO DEATH.
>> Dagen: THAT IS AMAZING.
THAT WAS A LONG TIME AGO.
BUT YOU MIGHT CONSIDER HOW
SOVIET CITIZENS FELT WHEN THEY
HEARD A FREE PERSON IN IN A FREE
COUNTRY PAPERING OVER THEIR
MISERY DOING PUBLICITY FOR THEIR
DICTATOR.
HAS BERNIE CHANGED MUCH?
HAS LEARNED NOT TO MINIMIZE THE
TRAGEDIES OF TOTALITARIANISM?
HERE HE WAS ON THE ""LAST NIGHT
>> ARE VERY OPPOSED TO THE IT’S
UNFAIR TO SAY EVERYTHING WAS BAD
BAD.
WHEN FIDEL CASTRO CAME IN THE
OFFICE, YOU KNOW WHAT HE DID?
HE HAD A MASSIVE LITERACY
PROGRAM.
IS THAT A BAD THING TO ME EVEN
THOUGH FIDEL CASTRO DID IT?
>> Greg: THEY JOKE THAT THE
LEFT BRINGS UP WHEN YOU WAVE THE
RAVAGES OF COMMUNISM.
YES, TED BUNDY WAS A GREAT
DANCER AND CHARLES MANSON PLAYED
DECENT GUITAR.
ADMITTING CASTRO DID BAD THINGS?
THAT’S PROGRESS.
AS BERNIE A STORM TOWARDS
NOMINATION, REMEMBERED THE
HISTORY, THE GOOD AND THE BAD,
AND REMEMBER WHAT SIDE BERNIE
CHOSE.
MURDEROUS TYRANTS.
IS THAT A BAD THING TO HIM EVEN
THOUGH A LEADING DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE DID IT?
THE ANSWER?
IT’S BAD.
IN HIS EIGHTH DECADE, A LONG
ADULT LIFE TO RECONSIDER.
STILL CAN’T GET IT STRAIGHT.
WELCOME BACK, ONE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
IS IT GOOD TO BE BACK?
TOURING DISNEY AND
UNIVERSAL STUDIOS AND NOW YOU
ARE BACK WITH THE ADULTS.
>> Juan: I WAS IN THE HOME OF
KIDDY CAPITALISM.
>> Greg: I THINK THIS A FAIR
COMPARISON, THE WEAKNESS OF A
RIGHT IS A DESIRE TO EXPORT
VALUES TO COUNTRIES, BUT THE
WEAKNESS OF THE LEFT IS TO
ROMANCE ANY RADICAL MOVEMENT.
THE MATTER IF IT’S CUBA, THE
SOVIET UNION, EL SALVADOR,
NICARAGUA, THEY’VE NEVER MET A
REVOLUTIONARY CAUSE THAT THEY
DID NOT LIKE.
IT ISN’T THAT KIND OF WEAKNESS
THAT BERNIE EXPRESSES, MAYBE?
>> Juan: I THINK THAT’S RIGHT.
THE PROBLEM AT THE MOMENT IS I
THINK THERE ARE PEOPLE BOTH ON
THE LEFT IN THE RIGHT WHO DON’T
UNDERSTAND HOW POPULAR BERNIE’S
RHETORIC IS.
THIS IS A SHOCK TO ME BECAUSE
I’M ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO DIDN’T
REALIZE IT, BUT THE FACT IS
THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE COME UP
PEOPLE FACING MOUNTING MEDICAL
BILLS.
THEY DO NOT CARE IF
BERNIE SANDERS SAID, YEAH, FIDEL
CASTRO WAS NOT THAT BAD.
THEY DO NOT CARRY NOT CARE
BERNIE SANDERS SAYS, I DON’T
KNOW HOW I’M GOING TO PAY FOR
IT.
THEY SAY, WAIT A MINUTE, MY
VEHICLE BILLS ARE OVERWHELMING,
GOT PROBLEMS IN MY PERSONAL
LIFE, I SEE IT THROUGH MY PRISM,
BERNIE SANDERS SAYS THIS IS
GOING TO HELP ME.
THIS IS THE POPULIST APPEAL THAT
TRUMP HAD FROM THE RIGHT?
THIS AS THE POPULIST APPEAL FROM
THE LEFT.
WE LIVE IN A POPULIST POLITICAL
ERA.
>> Dagen: THIS COULD BE THE
MIRROR OF TRUMP.
WE DO HAVE A TAPE
>> Greg: LET’SPLAY THAT.
>> DO YOU HAVE A PRICE TAG FOR
ALL OF THIS?
>> WE DO.
THE PRICE TAG IS IT’LL BE
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS THAN THE
CURRENT SYSTEM.
I THINK IT’S ABOUT 30 TRILLION.
>> THAT’S JUST FOR MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
DO YOU HAVE A PRICE TAG --
BIG ON THEM I DON’T.
YOU
WE PAY FOR THAT THROUGH A MODEST
TAX ON WALL STREET SPECULATION.
>> YOU DON’T SAY WHAT THE TOTAL
PRICE IS, BUT YOU KNOW HOW IT’S
GOING TO BE PAID FOR.
>> I CAN’T RATTLE OFF YOU EVERY
NICKEL AND EVERY DIME.
>> Greg: DANA, NO ONE CAN.
>> Dana: TODAY HE ANNOUNCED A
$1.5 TRILLION PROGRAM FOR CHILD
CARE.
THAT IS TRULY CRADLE TO THE
GRAVE.
FROM THE BEGINNING.
THE REVOLUTION, REVOLUCION, IS
INTOXICATING.
YOU’VE GOT TO WIN FLORIDA IF YOU
WANT TO WIN THE PRESIDENCY,
THAT’S A 50/50 PROPOSITION,
TRUMP HAS GOT THE EDGE.
YOU GOT SOMEONE LIKE DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESS FROM AND DONNA SHALALA
WHO REPRESENTS MIAMI COMES OUT
TODAY ON THE COULD OF ATROPHIED
AND SAYS, NO THAT’S NOT GOING TO
FLY WITH US DOWN HERE.
ANOTHER YOUNG CONGRESSMAN DID
THE SAME, BOTH DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THE TRUMP VERSUS BERNIE
CHANGE MAGICA CHANGE THE WAY WE
LOOK AT THE WORLD MAP.
WHAT’S INTERESTING, I WAS IN
COLORADO OVER THE WEEKEND WHERE
NO MATTER WHO WON IN THE STATE,
THEY WOULD PLEDGE ALL THE
DELEGATES TO WHOEVER WON THE
NATIONAL POPULAR VOTE, WHAT IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP WINS THE POPULAR
VOTE BECAUSE OF THIS?
ALL OF THAT EFFORT ON THE LEFT
WOULD’VE BEEN FOR NOTHING AND
THEY’LL TRY TO CHANGE A SYSTEM
FOR NO REASON.
>> Jesse: THERE GOES THAT
TALKING POINT.
CAN’T WAIT UNTIL THAT HAPPENS.
I JUST REALIZED, ONE, IF BERNIE
IS THE NOMINEE IS GOING TO HAVE
TO DEFEND BERNIE SANDERS FOR
NINE MONTHS.
IT’S GOING TO CHANGE THE WHOLE
DYNAMIC OF "THE FIVE."
ABOUT THE LITERACY PROGRAM,
GREG, THEY WERE TEACHING KIDS
HOW TO READ HEMINGWAY AND HOW TO
USE AN ADVERB.
THIS WAS A PROPAGANDA EFFORT.
THEY WERE HAVING THEM READ KARL
MARX.
THAT WASN’T THE LITERACY!
READ "THE COMMUNIST MANIFESTO."
THE OTHER THING HE PHRASES,
FIDEL HAD THREE BOTCHED
SURGERIES IN HIS COUNTRY BY
CUBAN DOCTORS.
THEY HAD TO SEND OUT A SURGEON
IN SPAIN THE COME BACK AND TRY
TO SAVE HIS LIFE, BUT HE DIED.
I DON’T KNOW HOW THEY ARE GOING
TO GET AROUND HIM PRAISING THE
SOVIET UNION, CASTRO, HUGO
CHAVEZ.
WHEN BERNIE NEEDS SENIORS FOR
HIM MORE THAN BLACKS, BECAUSE
SENIORS REMEMBER THE COLD WAR,
MONEY IN THE MARKETS, MAYBE THEY
OWNED A BUSINESS.
THEY WON’T FALL FOR A REPUBLICAN
BUT THEY AREN’T GOING TO VOTE
FOR A REVOLUTION AND THAT’S WHAT
BERNIE WANTS.
MY MOM TOLD ME SHE WILL NOT VOTE
FOR BERNIE SANDERS.
>> Greg: SHE’S VOTING FOR
TRUMP?
>> Jesse: NO.
SHE WILL NOT VOTE FOR BERNIE
BECAUSE, BERNIE CAN’T PAY FOR
ANYTHING.
IT DOESN’T ADD UP.
SHE ALSO DOES NOT LIKE BEING
YELLED AT.
BUT TO YOUR POINT -- NOT BY ME,
BUT BY BERNIE.
TO YOUR POINT, JUAN, BERNIE
MAKES PEOPLE FEEL LIKE HE CARES
ABOUT THEM.
WORKERS FEEL LIKE BERNIE CARES
AND IN THE ELECTION, THAT’S A
BIG POSITIVE PIECE OF EMPATHY
THAT YOU CAN COME OUT AND VOTE
FOR SOMEONE BASED ON.
>> Greg: IT’S THE SAME THING
WITH TRUMP, TRUMP FELT LIKE HE
WAS CONNECTING WITH THE VOTERS
AND THAT’S IMPORTANT, THE DAGEN.
WITH SANDERS, OFF THE BAT HE
ADMITTED THAT CASTRO IN CUBA DID
BAD THINGS.
TO ME, THAT’S A LITTLE BIT OF
GROWTH.
>> Dagen: HE’S GOT BETTER SOFT
PEDDLING HIS SUPPORT FOR
MURDERING DICTATORS AND
LEFTISTS, TO USE YOUR WORD,
TYRANTS.
GETTING BETTER TO GET PEOPLE TO
IGNORE IT.
IF YOU GO THROUGH THE LIST, YOU
SAID HUGO CHAVEZ, HE READ A
LETTER IN ’03, PEOPLE WHO KILLED
THEIR OWN PEOPLE AS AN OR
INTENTIONALLY PRETTY SUPPORTED
THE SOCIALIST WORKERS PARTY IN
1980 AND 1984, SUPPORTED SOVIET
LEADER DANIEL ORTEGA CALLING HIM
IMPRESSIVE, IT TAKES SENDS FOR A
REGIME TO SUPPRESS NEWSPAPERS.
HE ADVOCATED A 100% TYSON
ANYBODY MAKING MORE THAN THE
MILLION DOLLARS.
ASSERTED AS RECENTLY AS A
POTTERY 87 IT’LL TAKE OVER BY
THE GOVERNMENT OF CHINA AND
SWATHS OF THE ECONOMY AND THE
REASON SENIORS WILL VOTE FOR
HIM?
MEDICARE FOR ALL THE ONLY WIPES
AWAY 180 MILLION PEOPLE’S
PRIVATE INSURANCE WHO GET IT TO
THEIR EMPLOYER, IT ALSO FOLDS
MEDICARE INTO WHAT EXISTS TODAY
INTO HIS PLAN.
GETS RID OF MEDICARE AS IT
EXISTS TODAY.
TRY TO SIGN SOMEBODY ON THAT.
>> Juan: I REMEMBER 2016,
TRUMP SAID THIS, TRUMP DID THIS,
TRUMP CHANGE HIS OPINION ON
ABORTION, HE WAS A DEMOCRAT --
AND DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
THAT GUY IS PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: ’S THINGS LIKE THAT
MADE HIM STRONGER.
>> Dagen: HE’S RUNNING ON
TAKING HEALTH INSURANCE AWAY
FROM INDIVIDUALS AWAY FROM
AMERICANS ON MEDICARE AND FOUR
FOR THIS A MEDICAID GET THEIR
BENEFITS THROUGH PRIVATE
INSURANCE COMPANY.
THIS IS TODAY.
THE ONLY ARGUMENT THE LEFT HAS
IF BERNIE GETS THE NOMINATION
IS, WELL, YOU MIGHT NOT DO IT.